welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast as many of you know we typically
release an episode every two weeks but
in light of the kovat 19 pandemic we've
been trying to put out content more
frequently we know it's a tough time for
a lot of people many of you are cooped
up at home and looking for educational
or potentially enjoyable content we
recorded a fantastic interview with Jeff
Nippert a few months ago and we figured
now would be the perfect time to release
it Jeff's got a huge audience so some of
you may be joining us for the first time
if so thanks for stopping by also you
should probably be aware that Greg and I
are very very sarcastic people so as a
result we say some very distasteful very
disparaging things to Jeff so rest
assured we love Jeff it's only good fun
so don't take us too seriously anyway
Jeff is awesome he puts out exceptional
content on YouTube and he's got one of
the best natural physiques on the planet
in today's interview Jeff tells us all
about his approach to training nutrition
and even content creation this was a
really solid interview and we hope you
enjoy all right this is Eric Trexler
from stronger by science I'm here with
Greg knuckles and today we are joined by
Jeff nipper Jeff thank you for joining
us hey thanks for having me so Jeff I
want to dive right into the topics here
because we got a lot to talk about
the first thing I want to ask you you
know I have something written down here
I was gonna ask you how it feels to be
fake Nattie but I want to revise that
question to a two-part question okay
number one is how does it feel to be the
patron saint of the fake naty's well
number two would you like to use the
next 90 minutes to apologize I don't
know I didn't know we were gonna start
with this oh yeah driving right in okay
okay so you know I actually find lately
I haven't been getting that quite so
much it's interesting because with the
with the fake Nattie thing like in my
youtube comments someone undoubtedly
will throw that at me and then in
response it's it's rarely the case that
someone will just be like oh no you know
Jeff has just really dedicated the
better part of the last decade to
mastering his craft he's looked into you
know all the literature he's got a great
work at
and he's just built a great physique the
responses usually what are you kidding
me fake Matty this guy doesn't even look
like he lives like I kind of like the
guy calling me a fake Nattie better yeah
I was gonna say like Greg actually
called me out cuz somebody posted on one
of my pictures that like aw this guy's
on on the juice but it was like a very
old picture and he's like ah that sucks
you don't have it anymore
no one thinks your new pictures yeah
it'sit's simultaneously in accusation of
at least in America of federal felony
but also a pretty big compliment so it's
it's hard to tell how to how to respond
to that yeah I first when I first
started getting it I was really taking
it as a compliment but then people tend
to attach things to it like it somehow
lessens my credibility it's like oh you
can't trust him you know he's a fake
Nattie
so in my head I'm like well I could I
could stop trying so hard I mean I could
start looking a little worse maybe that
way that would help my credibility in
the eyes of some of my viewers but yeah
you know what it's it's one of those
topics that I've kind of just like
removed myself from because over the
years like I used to say you know look
at look at all these piss tests I've
passed
look at these polygraphs of past I've
competed since 2012 and if you look at
my physique the changes in my physique
from 2012 to now I mean they're in in
one sense kind of depressing I mean
they've just been very marginal with
like the natural waxes and wanes that
you see in physiques and nothing like
that really stands out as extraordinary
from my perspective and you know I've
shared all of those arguments like look
at my track record or do it I have other
characteristics that you'd see in people
who are deceptive or whatever
presented all the relevant literature
and the problems with FFM eye and
everything like that and it just doesn't
seem to do a single thing so I've pretty
much given up on answering that question
and at this point it's like does it
doesn't really matter I think Greg you
actually posted something really
enlightening to me about this when the
whole natty verified the thing was going
around and it was like the playing field
was never really even to be
with and I think the main issue with
fake naty's is the sense that they're
saying if you do X Y Z or you take X Y Z
supplements you'll look like me but
that's problematic whether or not the
person's using anabolics or not because
of all these other factors that you
can't control for I mean you're never
gonna look like really anyone else
regardless right so it's kind of like a
silly distinction to be making on the
face of it if that makes sense yeah I
mean like this is so I think Ray
Williams a stroke free but if Ray
Williams went out on social media and
said by my program and you'll squat a
thousand and fifty pounds that would
still be a shitty thing of him to do
because it's just not gonna happen you
know right exactly yeah and Jeff you
mentioned about a minute ago you
mentioned fat free mass index or FF mi
and a lot of times whenever people have
this discussion if somebody's natural or
not they kind of lean on that metric as
the be-all end-all metric only if it
supports the conclusion they wanted to
get at but do you happen to know like
the highest your fat free mass index has
ever been yeah so I did a DEXA I think
was early 2017 so about three years ago
and I came out at I think it was 8.4
percent body fat according to that Dex
at 162 pounds and five foot five inches
tall so when I plugged that in it came
out to be twenty four point seven so
barely in there right 25 is the cutoff
for natty right yeah sure yeah and then
there's another calculation that is
normalized FFM I so I think it just
further corrects for height so when I
plug it in for that value it's something
more like the high 25 or 26 something so
that puts me in fake 9t territory oh man
yeah it's that height adjustment they
get you every time
okay no we had a we had a question about
this on the podcast and somebody asked
as part of the question what mine was
kind of like at its highest
and I remember like my answer is like I
don't know probably not even close and
Greg was like maybe you should look into
it I think you have been close and he
was right but I have so little value for
that 25 cutoff that I've literally never
really like thought about it so I was
like oh I guess I did
maybe flirt with the fake natty line but
it is funny though because you get down
to the numbers of it like I've actually
argued on your behalf like I've heard
somebody saying Ah that Jeff Nippert
he's totally on the juice and I'm like
let's talk numbers here like these
aren't like absurd things that dude just
looks awesome because he is good at this
he's got good genes and his muscle
bellies are sick and like I feel like
nobody appreciates the fact that to
physiques with the same metrics in terms
of just sheer mass and body fat it can
look very very different yeah and so
that actually leads me into the next
question here you talked about with you
know natty or not it kind of doesn't
matter because it's not a level playing
field anyway we all kind of have our
strengths and weaknesses genetically how
much of your physique do you attribute
to to your genetics like do you consider
yourself to be like pretty above average
genetically for lifting I would say yeah
I would say above average for sure
both my parents were were recreational
bodybuilders and you know they trained
my mom and dad have been training for
gee I don't know at least probably 30
years apiece right so I would say the
genetic side for sure is in my favor but
also the environment side like I got
into lifting really early and
bodybuilding was just kind of normalized
around my house like my dad would wear
stringers to the gym in the 90s and
bodybuilding magazines lying around the
house he would eat his egg whites and
Hobie toast for breakfast and so I was
just around that growing up so as soon
as I turned 15 which was the the minimum
age requirement to lift at my local gym
you know he had me in there right away
so that was probably another big factor
that in some senses is outside my
control in addition to the actual genes
that they passed
to me that I can credit for where I kind
of ended up as far as like putting a
figure to it I find that's tough to do
like I would say when it comes to my
proportions insertions symmetry that
kind of stuff which like you just said
Eric can make a massive difference in
how impressive your physique appears
like I think there are plenty of guys
who aren't natural pro bodybuilders who
would have similar sets to me like 162 5
5 8 or 9 percent body fat doesn't I mean
it's good but it doesn't really jump off
the page but it's that roundness of the
muscle the way that they insert the
proportions that when posing under good
conditions just really can look
impressive and it's that side of my
physique that I attribute almost
entirely like near 100% to genetics I
think it also depends on who you're
comparing me to so for example if I were
to compete at natural bodybuilding
worlds I would say the differences
between those 10 or 12 guys on stage are
probably almost entirely attributable to
genetics as well because at that level
I'm assuming most people have figured
out you know what methods work well for
them everyone is lean which is what can
differentiate competitors at a lower
level shows and everyone's are hard
worker so I just feel like the actual
methods probably play into it a lot less
at a high level like that and the
differences between competitors probably
mostly due to genetics and judging if
you were to compare me to like an
average gym goer I would say in that
case I would give my hard work and my
methods a little bit more of the credit
there because I do think that if I
wasn't you know as dedicated and
committed and just consistent over the
years as I've been and I just went you
know through your typical like laxatives
achill training styles or whatever drank
on the weekends
did whatever with my diet I don't
think I would look anywhere near the way
I actually look so in that sense I would
say my genetics are still good but I
think the majority of my results can be
attributed to what I've you know done
with my training and died over the last
14 years does that make sense
definitely yeah I mean so the internet
informed me that your mom is in fact
like super jacked is your dad as jacked
as your mom is I think that if they were
to compete against each other in some
kind of twisted bodybuilding division my
mom would win I think she's just got the
3d delts she's got the the hardness and
density to the muscle but my dad has
definitely built up an impressive
physique but I think I got most of my
shape genetics from my mom for sure
especially like the shoulders in the
calves like my dad doesn't have my
calves but my mom does you know yeah so
you were born right into this thing did
you mentioned the time period you said
your dad would wear the stringers into
the gym did he have just an incredible
collection of fanny packs and do you
have access to any of them that's funny
I remember that but I remember when I
was like in that weird preteen stage
like I used to be embarrassed because he
would show up to like my basketball
games and stuff in in stringers with
like the gym bag trying to think of what
his age would have been at the time and
I was like dad you gotta stop was so
weird the bright pants too that I made
out yeah that's right that's right yeah
that's that's awesome that's honestly
like people say oh the fitness
industries change is not what it used to
be we should have kept it exactly there
where it was just stringers and and the
insane like super bright pants that was
when we peaked and it's all been
downhill since you know I think the the
cutoff sweatshirt arrow was pretty good
as well oh yeah that was good oh oh I
know what you're talking about
yeah like when everyone was rocking the
Bill Belichick look yeah or like in that
same era when they everybody wore a
shirt that was like 11 sizes too big and
just took scissors to it and whatever
you got was what you got I mean I still
would like to do that
if Lindsay made me throw I'll throw out
all of my like 5x else like scissor cut
shirts my two years ago I can't believe
she would do that dude they're the most
comfortable thing though I know I know
so so you were like born into this but
but obviously you mentioned a lot of
training over a lot of years and I think
that's something that Greg and I share
in common with you is that we got into
it pretty young you know relatively
speaking I know speaking for myself my
training for the first three years was
just trash like it would just absolutely
garbage so I guess my question is how is
your training evolved over the years
like like what was your training like
when you first got started so probably
similar to you I started with the body
part split that was what my my parents
did so yeah my mom and dad would take me
to the gym and we would do it was the
stereotypical one you know chest day on
Monday back Tuesday legs once a week
whatever and when I say like on my
channel that that was how I got started
I think people assume that I started
with that for you know I dabbled with it
for a couple of months and then got on
the right track from there but in
reality it was probably like five or six
years of consistent body parts split
training at the beginning and when you
think about it I mean that's probably
when I built most of my muscles so I
would say most of the physique I have
today was probably built off of a body
part split maybe you have a similar
story Eric I'm not I'm not entirely sure
what you started with I mean yeah I just
started with I wouldn't even give myself
that much credit so I started lifting
when I was 12 and so my first probably
year was just like oh I think I
understand which direction I'm supposed
to push this machine and then I just
take it for a ride but you know by 14 I
was at least doing a sensible body part
split kind of thing but but yeah I mean
you know at that age with no experience
you're gonna grow no matter what you're
doing but it comes back to what you're
saying though you mentioned like you
almost feel kind of sad looking back at
the last couple years of progress
because once you've put on most
you know a lot of your mass it's gonna
take a lot to continue building from
there I remember I saw Brian Whitaker
give a talk one time and Brian Whitaker
is awesome by the way multiple time
world champ I believe natural
bodybuilder but he in his presentation
he showed these two pictures of himself
and the point of his presentation was
like wow night and day difference but it
was from like him as like second in the
world to him as first in the world
I think 98% of the room couldn't tell
which was before and which was the after
but it's like it's like you're saying
those differences at that level and were
they like seven years apart as well I
think they were only like a year or two
okay yeah but he was like man could you
even believe that this progress was
possible and I think a lot of you were
like yeah your before pictures the best
physique I've ever seen so I don't know
what you want but now it's kind of a
similar thing I see some of these
transformations sometimes and I'm like
that could you know not to take away
from it at all but like sometimes the
the differences in physiques that you
see from from natural bodybuilders is
like you know that could be a difference
in one meal you know what I mean in just
terms of like muscle fullness or like a
change in lighting or something like
that it's kind of its kind of it can be
depressing when you think of it that way
but like especially if the lighting
conditions are different or whatever
it's like to the unaided eye or the
unaccustomed eye it would look almost
undetectable like you said definitely so
so you started out doing the body part
split and you went that route for a few
years and obviously still put on you
know plenty of muscle mass but what was
it that kind of caused you to reassess
things and try some other strategies
after that number of years mm-hmm
so after that I was introduced to a
style of training via the internet
called maximum overload training or max
ot training have you ever heard of it
yeah I've heard of it yeah okay so the
basic philosophy that this was that was
the one that Jeff will it that's right
right right yeah yeah yeah
Jeff Willett and skip liqueur so they
were the kind of natural bodybuilders
that I was really looking up to at the
time so this was around 2010 so I'd been
lifting for about five years now
should say that the way I did my bro
split I thought like handed down from my
parents I thought was effective because
there was good training advice in there
like my dad was really big on good
technique always you know controlling
the negative not using more weight than
you can handle
I think the volume was pretty standard
and in line with what I'd even recommend
today so there might have been you know
some sub optimality in terms of the
training frequency but I just think that
if you stretch that out across enough
time then and you know all the other
relevant factors are in place and are
okay then I'm not a hundred percent
convinced that like it would have made
an enormous a difference for me I mean I
probably would have gotten results a bit
faster had I have started with something
more optimally more optimal no doubt but
yeah just to clarify like I don't think
that it was a training they're a
terrible training split and I just got
results by fluke or something like that
I think that the rest of it was actually
pretty reasonably well designed but
anyway back to to max ot training so the
idea there was that you would at any
cost
overload from one workout to the next so
it was a very volume protocol for
example the leg day would have you doing
like three sets of squats three sets of
leg curls that's it but every set was
taken to failure in every set you had to
do more weight or one more rep than you
did the previous week and all reps
across all exercises were in the four to
six rep range so it sounds kind of
bizarre and once a week training
frequency and I ran that style of
training for about a year and I think it
was actually in the context of my entire
training career quite important because
it really forced me to get comfortable
with training super hard and really
pushed progressive overload in
retrospect I think it pushed it too hard
because it was kind of built into that
style of training that you should
overload at any cost even if that means
using a bit more momentum cheating a
little bit you just you have to get to
that extra five pounds on the bar or get
that extra rep out or what have you but
I think that there were some good
nuggets built into that program and I
think I attribute you know my comfort
ability with knowing for example how
many reps I have in reserve in my
current training to knowing exactly what
it feels like to go all the way to
failure and I think I owe that to max ot
training no I agree with you
wholeheartedly I think we've talked
about that on the podcast before that
like whether or not training to failure
all the time is necessarily the best
thing to do I think that at minimum it's
an important thing to gain a fair amount
of experience with at some point in your
training career preferably fairly early
on just just so like yeah I mean hard
training is hard and until you have
abundant experience doing it it's it's
fairly easy to delude yourself into
thinking you're going pretty hard when
realistically you're leaving way more in
the tank than you think you are yeah
yeah and you know a lot of the programs
nowadays we kind of talked to Mike to
Shir about this right a lot of them
asked trainees like okay leave a couple
in the tank or whatever but if you
really if you've never really figured
out where to anchor that scale and what
that real failure looks like with some
experience I think a lot of people are
really kind of leaving a lot in the tank
and not knowing it dude if you're doing
if you're doing say moderate rep squats
and you're supposed to leave a rep or
two in the tank dude a set of 10 squats
with one rep in the tank is a [ __ ]
hard set of squats like I mean it's it's
tough it's gonna suck pretty hard and
and I think I think a lot of people just
don't get that as an aside I forgot how
[ __ ] big Jeff will it was we have
pictures I've been pulled up right now
Jesus Christ Burton for a drug-tested
bodybuilder he was huge
huge yeah one of the all-time greats for
sure so you kind of transition from a
typical you know body part split to kind
of typical body bullying kind of split
you tried out the max ot but that still
sounds like it's a low-frequency thing
right yeah it was low frequency the the
difference with this was that it was
very low volume in very high effort very
high intensity and that was kind of
another thing that I liked about it
because it was different in that sense
but it made the training feel very
manageable it was like you know I only
had to go in and destroy these three
sets of dips and then you know I could
wipe my hands its clean and be done with
the workout kind of thing
and I don't know in retrospect it's like
that was a cool manageable way to train
I feel like you know I learned quite a
lot from this style and now currently
you know obviously I take more of a
higher volume or moderate effort
approach but just you know talking about
it here now it reminds me that like if
you're gonna go all out then the you
need to correct for that by lowering the
volume which which this routine did
quite well but so nowadays it sounds
like you're doing a lot of like some
really high frequency stuff right mm-hm
and so I guess did you kind of work your
way up through various programs and kind
of realize that that you responded
better with higher frequency so after
max ot I that was when I started that's
when I that's when I was introduced to
the fact that there is a science-based
bodybuilding community so this would
have been around like 2011 or 2012 and
that was when I started with upper lower
split push-pull leg split or you know
some kind of hybrid split of those but
shortly thereafter was when I started
really getting interested in
powerlifting so this was inspired by
lean Norton he was a natural bodybuilder
I really looked up to actually hired him
for one prep and he was having a lot of
success with combined powerlifting
bodybuilding so at the time I thought
hey I've never really given this
powerlifting thing a shot let me try
that and
a part of that I mean this was this band
probably two years that I would have
considered myself a pure power lifter
more or less even though I still I guess
in the back of my mind had bodybuilding
goals I was competing in powerlifting I
did something like six powerlifting
needs so I've done about as much
competition in powerlifting as I have in
bodybuilding I don't think a lot of
people know that but it was during this
timeframe that I experimented first with
high frequency training so I've you know
run phases where I'd squat five days a
week
bench four or five days a week I even
did a high frequency deadlift program
which I actually think might have been
what ultimately got me injured and that
that was my first taste of high
frequency then from there due to injury
I kind of got out of the powerlifting
world and went back to more of the like
quote-unquote science-based splits so
like push-pull legs up or lower and now
in the last year I've been experimenting
with a high frequency bodybuilding setup
so like a high frequency full body
routine where it isn't just like you're
training one lifts with high frequency
or pretty much training all the muscles
with high frequency so now you guys are
fully up to speed yeah I was gonna say
before you get fully into the high
frequency stuff I just wanted to mention
that I like I feel sick to my stomach
right now because the trajectory that
you just described and even the Year
ranges is the exact path I took and I'm
realizing that like if I didn't
completely suck at everything you're the
you're in the parallel universe where I
would have actually been good at any of
that stuff and it's making me so angry
and sick to my stomach because like I
mean the same thing like 2012 ish for a
couple years there I got into
powerlifting ended up getting hurt said
screw it I guess I'm gonna do
bodybuilding again it's just it hurts me
to know what could have been if I didn't
suck now Erik you don't have to be so
humble
just out of curiosity Jeff how many pro
cards do you have
right I have a singular pro card and it
might be expired you're talking you're
talking to the bo Jackson of physique
sports right now in that to be clear as
Erica not me
yeah that is true III should stop being
so hard on myself so but before we get
into high-frequency stuff like full-bore
I have kind of like a philosophical
question for you so you've talked you
mentioned several times in your answer
how you know you weren't doing whatever
was like quote unquote evidence-based
and you you know went through a period
of doing that and you know based on the
content you put out you clearly stay up
to date with the research fairly well
and and value evidence but one of the
things that I like to ask people and
something I think about a lot myself
that I personally don't have a great
answer to is when you read research on
you know gains after different training
methods one of the things you need to
keep in mind is you know you're looking
at rate of progress over you know two
months three months four months and we
don't really know whether you can
necessarily extrapolate that out and say
oh this program that gives me more
muscle growth over three months will let
me eventually grow more muscle over ten
years so maybe it gets you to a similar
point but it just gets you there a
little bit faster how do you feel about
that just personally so you know kind of
extrapolating short commader at term
research findings to long-term results
do you think that you know methods that
tend to show more muscle growth over
three months will eventually lead to
more muscle growth over ten years and
help you get a little bit closer to your
you know quote unquote genetic potential
limit or do you think that it is just
kind of a speed thing and you you're you
kind of wind up in about the same place
regardless yeah that's a good question
I think my instrument on the mood that
I'm in like days I'm feeling more
nihilistic I might think it doesn't
really matter as long as you're
consistent with it over time you'll
probably hit your natty limit
regardless lately I think especially now
that I feel like I have been having
great results with a new protocol I tend
to lean maybe the other way thing
that some methods are inherently more
optimal over the long term and probably
would push you further than if you were
just sticking to the same suboptimal
methods but being consistent with them
so for example like to put it this way
if I was still running say my dad's bro
split now I don't think I would be I
would get as far as I would with the
program as I would with the program I'm
actually running so at the moment I'd
say my answer would lean towards I think
you probably can in some sense
extrapolate that out to say there are
certain methods that are better for more
advanced trainees and if you use them
you can kind of raise your genetics
ceiling if that makes sense no fair
enough
and just I kind of feel the same way it
does very much depend on my mood to
follow up on that and obviously this is
a completely unanswerable question
objectively but just how how large of a
relative difference do you think that
makes you know like do you think it is
gonna be like a night and day difference
or do you think like maybe if I train
better or more quote-unquote optimally
in the long run maybe I wind up five
percent or ten percent better than I
would have otherwise well I would say
it's its marginal differences it's you
know more like the the five to ten
percent figure but I think where this
question has its practical value is when
you start combining these different
methods and this is something I've
noticed so you know throughout like my
experience with all of this stuff I've
gone through phases where I become very
convinced that this is the thing that
matters so for you know we were just
talking about max ot training it was
like you've got to go all out every set
in add weight or add reps every workout
otherwise this stuff isn't going to work
at all over time you start experimenting
with more stuff and you realize oh wait
a minute all this stuff seems to work
and then you you know start reading some
literature and you realize oh you know
the effects of these different things
are much smaller
then we thought maybe it all does just
kind of come down to genetics and you
can kind of just do whatever yeah as
long as you're consistent with it you'll
get there eventually and it you know
none of this stuff really matters that
much but when I take that fatalistic
viewpoint
it really does I find cause me to do
less and get inferior results so I think
it's when you stack these different
layers of optimality that you can really
move the needle in terms of physique
progression and that's something I've
noticed a bit more lately it's like when
I take more of a laksa days ago approach
to my nutrition so for example it's like
you know my protein intake whatever the
standards in the literature pretty low
at this point I mean I'd have to try to
not really hit those protein before bed
maybe that makes a small difference but
it's not really worth worrying about
I'll just have a bag of popcorn and call
it a day and a pre and post-workout
nutrition whatever nutrient timing
revisited paper from 2014 kind of
debunked that and when you start
stacking these things together it's like
well when you add them up and you're
consistent with all of them maybe that
is what is actually required to take you
from where you currently are to you know
where you want to be and so in that
sense I would say it really it really
does make a difference you know and it's
when I'm in moods like this that things
tend to be firing so like at the moment
my trainings going well I'm tracking my
macros timing my meals appropriately and
I'm seeing the results for it and so
that leads me to think that maybe in
isolation each one of these individual
factors aren't really moving the needle
that much but when you combine them and
you really get all your ducks in a row
that's when it can make a big difference
yeah I mean getting back to that that
question that Gregg asked about you know
does it all end in the same place but
we're just talking about referent rates
you know one of the ways I this is my
second time randomly bringing him up but
when we when we talked to Mike to shear
you know he had a world class he was a
world class strength athlete
when Greg and I were in high school you
know like Jeff you've had a world-class
physique for a few years now you know
what I mean I feel like you and him are
both of that level where the real
functional question is you know the way
he put it
am i out of rocks to turn over do I
really believe that there's no other
strategy out there to be explored that
could take me just a little bit further
along in my journey and and I feel like
when you reframe the question that way
there's there's always something else
right there's only something you could
go try and experiment with that might be
able to bring you just a little bit
closer to your true absolute sealing if
that makes sense I would say even more
than that too though like there may be
say you know there may be rocks that
haven't been turned over so that is to
say things that you haven't tried yet
that you could try but there could also
be things that you've tried before and
have worked for you before but you're
just for whatever reason not doing them
and in my case I think it just comes
from laziness or this mindset that you
know like we said it's like does it
really matter like I'm so close to my
genetic limitation at this point it's
easy to just be nonchalant with
everything but I think that if a lot of
people and I think maybe a lot of your
listeners since it is probably you know
a more advanced demographic might be in
this situation where you feel like
you've been doing this for long enough
that at this point it really doesn't
matter but if you just make yourself
accountable and follow through on the
things that you think might matter a bit
like I said they could add up and that
could actually make a profound
difference on where you end up so there
would be two things there right you you
know try out new things that you haven't
really tried before in my case that
would be like this new high frequency
thing and the other thing would be do
things that maybe you used to do and you
just got lazy and just don't really do
anymore I feel like you're attacking me
that's exactly what I need to somehow
tap into 20 year old Eric that thought
bench-pressing
was the most important thing in his life
all right I need to get back to that
because like even if you know even if
you can get behind it it just tends to
change the way you approach your days
the way you approach the gym and
I think that that mentality of I'm gonna
do my best with this can make all the
difference and having the opposite
mentality which I find a lot of people
in this you know science-based sphere
tend to have which is more fatalistic it
it can only I mean it can only work
against you right I mean a lot of the
things that we're talking about are at
worst neutral to slightly positive so I
prefer at least at the moment to have a
more optimistic view toward those things
yeah until your next injury then you say
nothing matters it's all exactly from
now man this will be totally different
just messing with you but I do want to
get back to you know we've kind of
hinted at this high-frequency training a
few times I know it's something you've
put out content about it well what
exactly does this high-frequency
training look like for you what I mean
what what would it what does it look
like in application mm-hmm you're I
think I heard on a podcast that you're
running this yourself Eric are you at
least dabbled in it for a while is that
right when I strung a few workouts
together I did yeah like I said I'm
being attacked right now by you talking
about actually doing stuff that has
worked for you but okay I I did it for a
few weeks and it did seem to be pretty
cool mm-hmm so I've played around with a
few different ways to do this I I kind
of borrowed the way I set it up from
Eric so we were in Australia we both
presented at the ultimate evidence-based
fitness conference there and this was a
focus of Eric's presentation and he kind
of I think presented it more as a way of
mitigating fatigue during contest prep
it ultimately to me sounded like it
boiled down to he just doesn't need to
do a leg day with the high-frequency
setup and in that sense workouts were
just more manageable and you got the
same stimulus for Less at least
perceived
fatigue so it just made contest prep a
bit easier I suppose it psychologically
if nothing else and so he didn't really
explain in the talk exactly how he had
set it up but the way I understood it
was you would take you know the volume
that you would do on any split so say
push-pull leg split and just kind of
evenly distribute those exercises out
throughout the week so for example let's
say you had your leg day on day one
you'd hit your squat day two you know
you could do your lying leg curl day
three you could do your leg press day
four do your RDL and then maybe you know
hip abductions or something like that on
day five and that would just be you know
for the lower body how you could spread
it out throughout the week and if that
sounds like it's not quite enough volume
then you could sprinkle in maybe some
leg extensions on the same day you do
leg curls or whatever but that's kind of
the general thought is just figure out
the volume you need and then space it
out throughout the week with this idea
in mind that certain exercises are going
to have greater recovery demands than
others so like you might not want to you
know put
squats and rdls one day after another
like you might might want to have a less
damaging exercise to kind of bracket the
two of those so it actually took a bit
of experimentation on my end to figure
out exactly the right setup so I felt
recovered from day to day but that's
generally how I think about it well yeah
because I mean this you know we talked
about how we got started back in the day
and I mean the only thing we knew for
certain is that you never train a muscle
group two days in a row right that was
the only rule that cannot be broken but
but inevitably you must be doing that
with this split right yeah you know when
I say it I think people picture that I'm
hitting a full workout for every body
part every day so it's like I'm training
every body part every day so they
picture I'm doing you know maybe some
kind of truncated chest workout and then
some kind of back workout and then
they're just like this is ridiculous you
know whereas in reality I mean if you
look at the sessions
it's fairly manageable like three sets
of pull downs one day and then the next
day you do three sets of cable rows I
mean it just doesn't seem to be that
much of a recovery demand from three
sets of pull downs so when you actually
look at it on paper with the exercises
written out I don't think it's really a
violation of that general recovery
principle that would say you know you
shouldn't train the same exercises on
consecutive days I mean in other
contexts that's just that would just be
violated all the time like I feel like
that's a bodybuilding rule that
bodybuilders have but like other
athletes don't really adhere to that I
mean I definitely didn't adhere to that
in my powerlifting days and I didn't you
know I did get injured but I don't
attribute it to the frequency per se and
I you know at the time felt like I was
recovering just fine and currently feel
like I'm recovering just fine so I don't
think you can look at it in a vacuum and
say you know this is the rule it's like
well it clearly depends on how much
volume you're doing what exercises
you're doing and how intensely you're
doing it I feel like this is a very non
evidence-based way of looking at things
but one of the things you'll you'll
notice if you just look around in the
world is you know I'd say probably like
ifbb pro bodybuilders have the best
forearms in the world but as a close
second we're close second would probably
be grip grip competitors as a close
third would be manual laborers if you're
swinging a hammer all day or carrying
cinder blocks all day or you know
working on a roofing crew and like
carrying shingles and also swinging a
hammer those guys get enormous forearms
like bigger than bigger than most power
lifters who you know mostly just train
their forearms deadlifting and so like
you know they're not doing dedicated
training for their forearms but they're
getting some degree of stimulus to those
muscles everyday but not enough to inclu
to accrue the type of fatigue debt that
would make it to where they couldn't go
into work and earn a paycheck the next
day and so it seems to me like you're
kind of functioning
kind of a similar principle to that of
you know go in stimulate the muscles
both most days but not so much that you
know they're they're too worn down to
stimulate again the next day mm-hmm
another thing I noticed with this is
that when I first started it I did feel
like it wouldn't be sustainable over the
long term and that's because probably
just you know in part due to my own
stubbornness so I would find it hard to
go in the gym and just do you know three
sets a lot pull downs and be done
because I'm so used to having these
really high volume back workouts so I'd
be like okay I gotta at least throw a
horizontal row or some face pulls at the
muscle as well right and there might've
been this like notion in the back of my
head that maybe there is a minimum
threshold per session for growth so I
was like I want to at least play it safe
and make sure I hit that and then also
there's probably a minimum effort so got
to make sure I'm pushing it hard enough
and it just ended up being too much
initially so I kind of started over and
was like okay I'm for the first couple
weeks I'm gonna really adapt to the
higher frequency not gonna train as hard
as I normally would gonna do
significantly less per session volume
even though per week volume would have
been about the same than I normally
would and then once I did that for a
couple weeks
I found it was my recovery was so good
to the point that I could actually train
pretty hard take some sets to failure
and I didn't feel like it was affecting
me in any way the next day so there's
this idea that if you're running a
high-frequency split you need to train
at a very low effort and I think that
that's true initially at least for me
but I find once you grow accustomed to
it it's really not that hard to push
yourself within a reasonable proximity
to failure and still be recovered by the
next day I don't know if I would
necessarily recommend that broadly but
that has been my experience so far it's
like the more I get comfortable with the
frequency the more I feel like I can
ramp up the intensity and the recovery
not feel as overbearing as it did when I
first started
I mean that that is what you would
expect but I feel like there is still
this like ongoing perception that like
you just can't train hard on a
high-frequency split which I just
haven't found that to be the case except
for at the very beginning you know you
bring up a really good point because as
you mentioned I have kind of dabbled in
some of this stuff and one of the
hardest habits to break like I've done a
25 set arm workout you know I've done a
good 20 to set chest workout it is
really hard if you get in the habit of
being a you know a bodybuilder and like
an arm day is done when you literally
can't lift your arms anymore if you try
to bring that mindset into this kind of
high frequency full-body stuff that's a
really great way to mess it up and just
have an awful time right like if you
don't have that discipline to say listen
it was three sets a lap pull down move
on that can be something that I would
anticipate a lot of bodybuilders mess up
that transition until they learn the
lesson and say okay I got a I got to get
back on it well I think this illustrates
a point I've tried to make on the
podcast a few times that like a lot of
times training advice is very
context-specific and you can't you can't
just extract what seems to be effective
variables from one training routine plop
it into another training routine and
expect things to go well so the example
I always tend to use is like Westside
style training has worked really really
well for a lot of people Shaco style
training has worked really really well
for a lot of people but if you combined
the super-high crazy intensity of
Westside with the frequency and really
really high volumes of Shaco you're
gonna kill yourself like that that you
can you can take to effective things
take the effective things from them mash
them together and wind up with something
way way worse and less effective than
either of the two things you were
drawing from and so that sounds pretty
similar to what you're what well but
both of you are describing right here
big-time yeah now Jeff so when did you
start this high frequency training split
how long you been doing it so I did my
first workout I think
the first workout I did was actually
with Eric and you can watch that video
on my channel if you like so that would
have been in the summer of 2019 I think
maybe July so whatever that is six seven
months something like that so since then
I ran a few different variations on it
and the one I've landed on is this kind
of I guess minimalistic in a sense that
you're not trying to balance too much at
one time somewhere in there I tried to
sprinkle in a bit more of a power
lifting focus and I just found it was a
little bit too much with the high
frequency and yeah but yeah it's been
probably about six seven six seven
months something like that six or seven
months and at first you noted that you
kind of had to adjust how you viewed you
know distributing that volume and
intensity have you found that as you
eased into it as your recovery improved
that volume like weekly volume kind of
drifted up over time yeah a bit so I
write my programs ahead of time so I
naturally try to do that I've naturally
try to either increase the reps or add a
set here and there especially for body
parts that I'm working on but I feel
like my tolerance has increased but I've
been more I think focused on the effort
side of that equation before turning to
increasing volume I've been trying to
make sure that I'm pushing myself
sufficiently hard because I think you
know I don't think there's anything I
should say this upfront I don't think
there's anything really special about
training at a higher frequency certainly
not special enough to override training
intensity so let's just imagine it were
the case that I was never able to get
past that early hump where I wasn't you
know I was having to leave four or five
reps in the tank for every set I don't
think it would be worth it in that case
I just don't think there's that much of
an inherent advantage to high training
frequency so what you got to think about
is there has to be a way that I still am
able to push myself sufficiently hard if
I'm gonna run this split otherwise I
don't think it's worth it
so that's been kind of my focus before
turning to you know really ramping up
volume or whatever because that my stage
I kind of know the amount of volume I
think I need and I think once you start
throwing a lot of variables at this it's
like okay you know I've already uh it's
only been six months
I've already up the frequency now I'm
really you know taking sets a little
closer to failure let's just go ahead
and ramp up the volume to it's like you
kind of got to pick and choose your
variables wisely
you know no I got you that makes a ton
of sense so one of the things this
reminded me of is one of the concepts
that I've seen floating around in the
quote unquote evidence-based Fitness
community I've seen James Krieger talk
about this scene you know Hensel men's
talk about this is the idea that you
know we we often talk about volume on
like a weekly basis so how many sets per
muscle group per week are you doing one
of the things that that they brought up
is when you look at the literature it
seems like maybe we should be talking
more about like a concept of more like
optimal volume per session where you
know there's a fairly like low -
reasonable per session volume that seems
to be associated with the best results
so you know if if you split 30 sets per
week up as like you know six sessions of
five sets that maybe a little bit better
than you know just one session of 30
sets but maybe similar to like three
sessions of 10 sets are you aware of
that general concept and just overall
what do you think about it if you are
aware of it yeah for sure so there's
that paper out of the bar below lab
which has come under scrutiny recently I
don't know if you're aware of this the
the new hip thrust and squat study have
you guys have you guys looked into that
have you spoke about that on the podcast
yet we haven't spoken about it on the
podcast but this won't be the time you
will likely have something to say about
it at some point okay I'm really excited
for that because I feel like there's
been a lot of really interesting
discussion around that study so I'd love
to hear your guys take
on it I've met a lot of takes and all of
them are bad
all of them are hot muy caliente okay
that's that's a good teaser right there
they're all bad so I'm excited to hear
the good one um so anyway out of that
lab so I know they published a study it
was like evidence for an upper ceiling
of volume per workout so based on that
it's it seems to be that yeah that is
what you should look at you know you
should consider how much volume you're
doing in a session not just you know in
a week and I think even maybe more than
that you you want to also consider how
long the sessions are taking like for me
you know say I'm doing upper/lower
twice a week right so up or twice a week
lower twice a week with the amount of
volume I need to do sometimes those
sessions just go on and on I mean some
of the leg days it's like you've got
squats already Elle's lunges leg curls
calves
maybe abs at the end it's like sometimes
the the workout just feels unbearable in
a sense so even if there's nothing say
inherently physiologically superior to
spacing that volume out so that you have
like you said a more low to moderate per
session volume psychologically I think
it actually does make a big difference
and that's probably been the single
biggest benefit I've noticed to adopting
this training style is just the fact
that I don't need to have a two-hour leg
day to get all my weekly volume crammed
in across to set two sessions it's like
once you get sufficiently advanced on
these split routines in order to get the
volume you need the workouts are gonna
be fairly grueling and toward the end of
these sessions no matter what kind of
dedication you have I feel like your
performance is going to start to slip at
a certain point I mean that may not be
true of everyone but I've found that
with this high frequency setup I don't
notice that same psychological fatigue
for lack of a better word yeah I mean it
obviously makes the work
I feel really fresh right you know
you're you do your three or four sets of
whatever your you're doing for chest
that day maybe they go well maybe they
don't but you're like all right time to
move on and you're onto a different
muscle group and you can at least switch
things up a little bit within the
workout I mean there's nothing worse
than when you do like the first two sets
of your leg day and you're like well
those sucked but 90 more minutes where
that came from immediately exactly yeah
it's that's the worst place to be so so
you've been doing this for a while
you've you know trouble shot things
you've kind of figured out the structure
that works for you so you know having
been through it for a while now
what are some of the pros and cons and
ultimately you know what kind of results
are you getting from it so I did a full
video a couple weeks ago recapping all
the pros and cons I think I had four
cons that I went through an eight pros
so maybe you can link that video below
cuz off the top of my head I might not
remember them all in it might for people
who might not be interested in that but
the cons mostly came for me in the first
couple weeks so like I said there was
that trial and error period where I felt
like I was doing too much I was getting
too sore I was too fatigued the soreness
part was a big one for me because I'm
one of those people who just get super
sore and it lasts forever like I can do
rdls
and be sore for a week I've had to miss
school like when I was in university
I've had to miss like the no joke and I
was a dedicated student because of leg
day due to soreness I've been on
crutches from leg day that's not an
exaggeration yeah it's crazy house where
I get that's some tom platt [ __ ] right
there I mean I used to train really
really hard but I still think there's
gotta be some genetic component to it
because you know even if I take even
after like a deal owed week or I take a
couple days off I come back and hit a
leg day guaranteed I'll be sore for four
or five days after it's crazy
so what initially was a major downside
of this because you know you can imagine
someone like me I would train my chest
let's say on Monday
now I've got to do flies on Tuesday my
chest is still sore from Monday right so
it's like it not only does it feel
uncomfortable it's just like that
there's a potential safety concern and
also maybe a performance concern too
right I mean pain has to inhibit
performance right
whether it's soreness or not so that
seemed like a big negative and it was
like is this even really worth it like
maybe for someone with my predisposition
to intense soreness maybe it just isn't
good for me but I'm really glad I stuck
with it because now I pretty much never
get sore at all which is great so it was
funny because when I said that in the
video there was a commenter who was like
Jeff goes to interview please tell me
about some of your weaknesses and it's
like well if you listen closely my
weaknesses are actually strengths I was
kind of how I presented it in the video
but that was probably the biggest thing
that I noticed I know I spoke about
workout length the workouts sometimes it
depends on the day but on some days I've
got say deadlift and benchpress to do in
the same session and then still you know
some isolation work for other muscles a
bit of a quirk whatever because you have
to do a pyramid warm-up for the
deadlifts and an also a pyramid warm-up
for the bench that can be time-consuming
if you're working up to pretty heavy
loads which you know relative to maybe
other people I probably am so I've found
some of those workouts can drone on a
bit so for people who you know don't
have a lot of time to spend in the gym
like for me it's usually like on average
probably about 90 minutes per workout
people who want to be in the gym less
than that maybe you'd be better off you
know doing an upper lower three day a
week split or something like that you
know but for me I you know I love being
in the gym I've got the schedule to be
able to do it so it's not really so much
of a downside that was pretty much it
for me I know a lot of people when they
level their criticisms at this they'll
mention joint stress and that could very
well be valid I haven't found it to be
the case with
me and that's speaking as someone who
has a history of injury I don't know I'd
be curious to hear your guys thoughts on
this because I would imagine you could
you could flip it the other way too
right you could say well if you're gonna
put all your leg work on just one day so
you've got squats leg press lunges leg
extensions I mean that's just so much
acute stress on the knee that that could
lead to you know an acute episode right
whereas the other side would say well if
you're gonna space those out it's so
much cumulative stress on the joints
that it could lead to an overuse injury
right I don't know if one is necessarily
better than the other and I think
personally I think it depends on how
hard are you pushing those sets what's
your technique like how are you
arranging the exercises and so on and so
forth so I haven't found the joint
concern to be legitimate personally but
I could I can see how people would raise
that as an argument against it Greg what
do you think oh man so I'm sure a bunch
of physical therapists are gonna send me
hate mail for a dancer injury doesn't
exist pain is all in the mind
caveat etc my general my general
observation with high frequency stuff is
that basically if an overuse injury does
start developing and you keep training
with pretty high frequency you can make
things really bad really quick much
worse and much quicker than you would
with a lower training frequency just
because you know you've you've caused
more stress to whatever tissue it is
then it has proven to be capable of
recovering from and adapting to on you
know in the short term and then you just
keep adding more and more stress to it
it can't you know fully adapt and
recover things get worse and worse and
worse pretty quickly because you're
applying that stress you know every
single day or four or five times a week
versus you know if you irritate
something but then it's gonna be a week
before you are you know exposing that
tissue to stress again
it does have a fair amount of time to
start getting on the mend versus with a
lower frequency I think that there is
there are some more inherent safeguards
in play from against making a bad
situation worse
just because you are exposing the
tissues to stress less frequently but
what how it seems to me at least is that
on kind of like a per exposure basis
your risk is higher because one of the
things that can happen is as you start
accruing a significant amount of fatigue
you know whether that be in the gym or
whether that be playing a sport but as
the muscles start fatiguing as they
start getting damaged as you have more
neural fatigue motor control starts
getting worse and worse and worse and
then like that that knot loss of motor
control but those decrements and motor
control can begin shifting stress from
very robust contractile tissues that can
take a lot of stress and handle it just
fine - soft issues that you know tendons
and moreso ligaments that shouldn't
necessarily be exposed to that stress so
I think that you know certainly on a on
a per-unit basis or like on a per
workout basis your risk of aggravating
something is probably higher with a with
a lower training frequency so it's yeah
I think it's it's mostly a trade-off
like and I think that trade-off can
largely be mitigated if you're not an
idiot with a high volume approach you
know when something does start bothering
you you know like hey I need to just
like maybe not put stress on my bicep
tendon for awhile or take it very very
easy with exercises that would load say
my bicep tendon if that's what was
bothering me so anyway I can't pretend
like I have citations for well I do I
would be able to provide citations for
some of that but not for literally every
part of that entire thesis but that's
that's broadly been my
my observation of how training frequency
relates especially to overuse injury I
got you when I did really high frequency
squatting and you know I've got a Greg
knows I've got a history of back
problems actually when I when I tried
some of the really high frequency stuff
more recently I did hurt my back and
that's why I fell off the wagon but it
was not because of the high frequency
stuff it was because I was an idiot and
thought I was stronger than I am which
happens sometimes but um in any case
when I was doing really I was squatting
like four or five days a week my back
has never felt better like I felt so
good because I mean I was managing the
loads properly and but yeah I I did have
concerns about it going into it but it
was like as long as your Manning's up
managing those loads really well the
fact that you're going back a few days
in a row doesn't at least in my
experience didn't really seem to be
inherently problematic you know now Jeff
if you were to say like there is a
certain person or a certain type of
person that this high frequency stuff is
great for or maybe a certain type of
person that should avoid it like who is
this good for and who is it bad for in
your opinion I would say again I I'm I'm
not really comfortable saying it's like
good in the sense that it's like
definitely superior to other protocols
like for me I think at this point I've
kind of tried everything else and it's
like hey you know here's another Rock I
can untorn right that that's kind of the
way that I look at it and I have just so
happened to find all these things about
it that I really like I would say
someone who is new to the gym definitely
doesn't need it you know a couple days a
week training frequency is going to be
plenty for most people for potentially
all their training career right so I
wouldn't recommend this for for people
who are new to the gym I'm still not
sure I would recommend it for people who
have concurrent strength and hypertrophy
goals like I think you want to use high
frequency either as a strength
specific thing where you're trying to
build up maybe one week lift so like if
your bench really sucks you could use
high-frequency to try to you know really
hone in on your technique and get some
more practice with that and by the same
token you know if you've tried
everything with so-called hypertrophy
training and you want something new to
give a shot you could give this a shot
and see if you find the same things that
I've found but I think if you're wanting
to do both of those things concurrently
like you want to get really strong and
you also want to get jacked
I would favor a different setup than
this because I just find you're just you
know kind of throwing too much at
yourself at once so for so-called
power builders I don't know if I would
recommend it and that's from I'm
speaking from experience because I tried
to integrate more strength stuff so I'd
you know squat a couple times a week
bench a couple times a week more like I
would on you know like a hybrid setup
with this but I think you should try to
direct your goal with high frequency
either toward quote unquote pure
hypertrophy or pure strength now that
isn't to say I don't I haven't I
actually have still gotten stronger
but I'm only squatting benching and dead
lifting once a week even on this high
frequency split and that's on purpose
because those exercises especially for
me are harder to recover from and
interestingly I think what has worked
better for me is adding top sets so I
will do a heavy double or triple before
I back often do my you know submaximal
volume work for those exercises and I
found that that on its own has been
enough to lead to strength gains for me
even though I've been approaching this
as a so-called hypertrophy setup you
know so just just to clarify so I think
I wouldn't recommend it for beginners
and I wouldn't recommend it for people
who have concurrent strength and
hypertrophy goals and are trying to
maximize on both of those the best they
can yeah I mean I can imagine
logistically it's hard to make all those
different pieces work you know within
this type of program
yeah now if you send me that link we can
go ahead and you mentioned there's a
video where you talk about the pros and
cons we'd be happy to put that in the
description here so people can go get
more information about the
high-frequency training approach that
you take
we did have some diet related questions
for you but we want to be respectful of
your time so I'm gonna ask the one that
I find most interesting and this is
something Greg and I have talked about
before my question for you is have you
ever done just an absolutely sick
dreamer bulk I knew that's what you were
going to ask of course I'm gonna ask so
of course of course I have Eric you know
my history dreamer book goes hand in
hand with the bro split early on awesome
so well let me say this when I first
started out with bodybuilding my dad and
mom they were both pretty hardcore clean
eaters so like typical bodybuilding type
diets like 5 or 6 meals a day protein
shakes in between meals that kind of
thing
so that was where I started out it was
very clean but when I did my first
bodybuilding show in 2009 at the time
the climate was after your show you try
to gain as much weight as you possibly
can
to the point that my training partner
and I we would cut at the same time we
would have a competition to see who
could gain the most weight after the
show has a really solid idea yeah yeah
it was literally like we called it we
would try to race to 200 pounds but the
thing is is when I would get in contest
shape at the time I'd be around 140 so I
was a bantamweight and he would get down
to like maybe one the high one 60s or
170 so he only had to gain about thirty
pounds and I had to gain 60 so what
actually ended up happening this
happened like you're a couple years was
I'd get 40 pounds on and then I just it
didn't matter what I did it no more
would go on so I would just cap out at
around 180 so plus 40 from my show which
on a guy who's like 5'4 or 55 that is a
significant increase in mass in a couple
short weeks so that those were my best
days as far as dream or bulking goes and
probably the best days of your life
there's nothing better than being in the
midst of a full-blown dreamer bulk well
it's interesting because back then it
the way I framed it psychologically was
purely positive it was like the more you
gained the more mass you were gonna have
for your next show which on some level
was probably true I'm not totally sure
cuz then I had to die it's so hard to
get it off but it was you're right it
was it was a very fun innocent kind of
naive way to approach it and yeah I do
miss those days sometimes so the reason
I asked it I could just hear the tone in
your voice changed as you were again
talking yourself into thinking it was
awesome so Greg and I have met I've
talked about this before I think if you
talk to people who are like pretty
experienced they're like oh yeah
I did a dreamer bulk it was pretty dumb
and yet everyone who got big and strong
has done it and we're like maybe there
was something to it you know like every
single person is like oh it's totally
unnecessary but it is the one thing that
every big strong person has done and
it's it's impossible to ignore that is
to some extent right yeah if nothing
else it's a simple way to be like hey if
you want to put on 20 pounds of muscle
gain 60 pounds
you'll get close right I think it
depends on whether or not you've like
taken the red pill is that the right use
of that expression and like realize that
it really depends how you're attempting
to use that expression okay it's either
it's either waking up and pulling
yourself out of the matrix or deciding
you really hate women ignore the H hand
interpretation or wherever it is they
choose that I meant the former so
basically what I mean by that is do you
realize yet that this is gonna have to
all come off you know because once you
realize that it might not be
a good idea but once you're naive to
that fact and you like because at the
time you really think that this is all
good mass you know and you just got
another eight weeks to get it off then
in reality you're like oh boy this is
gonna be a half a year prep to get back
down there again right so it depends on
your psychology but you know the
interesting thing is is like it was so
enjoyable for me when I thought it was a
good thing but then once I switched to
more of like an if it fits your macros
type approach and realize that there was
such thing as reverse dieting that I
should be doing then I framed it as
entirely negative despite the fact that
it still happened like after the
competition I never really I don't think
ever found a way to control my
insatiable appetite other than to just
gain the weight back and the only
difference I found was psychological
like early on I framed it as a good
thing I was getting all these sick gains
then later it was like oh no if I gain
so much I'm gonna have to work so hard
to dye it back down the next time and
you know I should be reverse dieting and
all this kind of stuff so whether you
interpret it in a positive or negative
light I just think depends on what you
what you know yeah I think ultimate and
you know this is a topic that is
fascinated me for a while specifically
looking at weight gain after a diet ends
and some of the research I did in grad
school you know what we generally found
is people tend to preferentially put on
a lot of fat in that immediate four to
six weeks after and I think there's
probably a middle ground where it's like
you want to gain some weight back if you
want to have some sanity and not have
just an outrageous appetite so there's
got to be a middle ground between like
fighting that weight gain and making it
a competition that's probably the sweet
spot but I was the same way as you the
first time I did a dreamer bulk I was
like I couldn't believe my luck this was
before I found out that muscle gains and
strength gains weren't necessarily the
same thing
so as my deadlift win
I got really fat and I was like oh this
is all muscle and then one of my
roommates at the time was like hey Eric
just wanted to let you know I love you
you're a good friend
but you're really fat and I don't think
anyone's gonna tell you except me and so
that that was the intervention that it
took for me to get out of out a dreamer
bulking that just reminded me of Greg's
story with his roommate where you had
you put him on a diet and he was
supposed to be drinking protein shakes
but he was in fact drinking weight
gainer shakes is that I get that right
yeah not my roommate one of my
classmates but yeah I mean long story
short
needed to lose a reasonable amount of
weight pretty quickly you know probably
like three or four pounds a week I said
hey man really the only thing that's
gonna give you a fighting chance here is
a protein sparing modified fast
explained to him in detail how to set
that up
gave him a fairly lengthy list of
adequate food choices for that and turns
out it wasn't going as well as he was
hoping he wasn't he wasn't shedding
weight at the rate he expected that he
was I had told him boneless skinless
chicken breasts and protein shakes
turned out bone-in skin-on chicken
thighs were a lot cheaper at Walmart and
he already had mass gainer on hand and
so his diet for the previous three weeks
had been bone-in skin-on chicken thighs
and mass gainer shakes and he was he was
shocked that he wasn't losing weight as
fast as he hoped I was I was crying the
first time I heard that because I have a
similar story I had a friend of mine who
when well first of all when we first
discovered that if it fits your macros
was a thing like we thought this was the
holy grail of nutrition right like we
couldn't believe this existed we could
eat whatever we wanted or whatever so
anyway at this point it was you know
it's still new to us and so I gave him
macros to follow and he just I was like
it's so crazy that you're not losing
weight on this and as it turns out he
didn't
realize that you had to track fluids it
was only solid food that he was tracking
so he was drinking like three or four
glasses of orange juice with every meal
not sorry three four glasses of orange
juice per day I like a glass with every
meal and I'm just like how can you not
you know realize that but in retrospect
it's like you know it's around the same
time that people would ask you know do
you need to track all sources of protein
or only complete protein sources like
you need to count the calories from
protein and bread and stuff like that
like it wasn't like no one had a clear
idea of just like yeah track it all
counts you know yeah there were like I
remember thinking the same thing like if
it fits your macros was just a complete
life changer but there was that time
where a lot of people first started
adopting it where there was like no
understanding of how to actually use it
and there was a lot of really frustrated
people all right so that Greg we're
keeping our tally that's another big
strong person who did in fact do a
dreamer bulk so well here's I think the
most important question did you come in
bigger at your next show
well actually I I was the same weight
but considerably more conditioned so I
guess but not as much not as much as
you'd hope though and I'm gonna shed a
bit of skepticism on this because I
recently at people who follow me will
know did an experiment it's basically
dreamer bulk except I called it bear
mode so the idea I got this from a
friend of mine he's a youtuber as well
Alex from the channel alpha destiny and
it's this idea that if you're natural
and you want to look big you know
walking around and clothes this kind of
thing then it's a requirement that you
be at a higher body fat percentage
so he says somewhere in the like fifteen
to twenty percent body fat zone and then
to disguise the fat or just disguise the
fact that you've got all this like fluff
on your body you grow body hair which
kind of adds the illusion of like a
graininess to the physique or whatever
right so
I experimented with this got up to my
you know usual dreamer ball cap of 180
or whatever and I think that because I'm
so advanced in my training at this point
that like it I honestly don't think it
made that much of a difference in muscle
mass so if you're if you're gonna do it
I would say to do it earlier on I feel
like it's more likely to have a
significant impact when you're still
primed to build muscle obviously then
later on and I've grown because of this
increasingly skeptical of the idea that
dreamer bulks do much of anything once
you're nearing your genetic limitation
yeah I feel I feel like I should put a
caveat in here I definitely don't think
dreamer bulks are a universally good
idea I think the reason I asked it is
because Greg and I always find it funny
that every person you ask oh say ah
definitely don't do it and then you say
did you and they go oh hell yeah you
know interview but and it was awesome
yeah but but no I logically speaking it
doesn't make a lot of sense you don't
have to overshoot your calories by that
much to put on muscle so for the three
of you who are listening to this for
actual information out there I'm not
saying you should dream or bulk we just
think it's funny that everyone says
definitely don't but hell yeah I did
alright with another little set of
questions here for you and then we'll
let you go for the day obviously you put
out really really sick content putting
out really killer videos on YouTube all
the time and I was hoping to get a
little bit of insight into how your
creative process works like you know how
do you decide what topics you're gonna
cover is it is it just kind of like
whatever you're living for your fitness
or like whatever you're trying at the
time like that's up next for content so
thanks man I appreciate that it does it
means a lot coming from you guys so
thank you when it comes to content for
me I've got an enormous list in my phone
of topics and they just they tend to
come to me randomly like it might be
something stupid I read in a car
and I'm like oh I need to clarify this
or or whatever or it could just be
another article that someone else posted
and I'm like yeah I could probably do a
different spin on that or whatever so I
just keep this running list in my phone
of cool ideas so I never have the issue
that I found a lot of content creators
have which is fear of running out of
ideas that is just like so far in the
future to me and I plan my content out
well in advance so like I know exactly
what videos I'm filming and uploading
for the next two or three months at
least and I've got a general plan of how
I want my content to look for all of
2020 so there's a lot of planning and
there's no shortage of ideas when it
comes to the specific upload strategy or
what videos I'm gonna make and how I'm
going to time them and everything
there's a model of content strategy on
YouTube actually dono what it's called
but you could call it the Triple H model
so you kind of want to think of like the
wrestler Triple H I was gonna sign with
that perfect so you kind of want to
think of your channel like an actual TV
channel in that it has multiple
different shows that might appeal to
different audiences to different degrees
and you can think of your videos as
three different bits of content so you
have first hero content so like
superhero content this is a type of
video that would go viral so it would
attract new people to your channel who
have never heard of you before
but it's enticing enough that they'd
click it and watch it and liked it and
then subscribe so that that's those
types of videos are big for outreach
they tend to be you know controversial
topics or things that just have
mainstream appeal so like if we were to
start a beef like I listened to that
episode where you guys were like just
beef with someone that's the that's the
content strategy in and of itself that
would probably fall under the hero
category or like a ten thousand calorie
challenge
or natty or not videos like those tend
to be hero videos in fitness spaces and
I try to do those occasionally like for
me they tend to be on body parts or
topics that a lot of people want to know
about so like AB videos tend to do
particularly well like arm videos bicep
stuff like the typical click baby videos
so and those are important from a growth
perspective because you know I'm not
saying that they're required to get
people watching but like it's a very
saturated space and if you're trying to
get new people into the channel you
sometimes it's just if you think it's an
evil it may be a necessary evil to do
those types of videos so that would be
the first type hero videos the other
type would be hub videos so those are
videos that you just make for your
current audience so that could be like a
training vlog an update on how things
are going with my diet physique update
or a topic that's a little more niched
so something that might not have
mainstream appeal but my audience might
get a lot out of so like say that the
the recap videos that I do for mass like
some of those topics your average gym
goer might not necessarily be interested
in it but there's a subset of my
subscribers who really are and the
intention there is not to go viral
you're just trying to make the best
content that you can for people who are
interested in what you have to say and
then the third type would be a help
video so this would be like how to
benchpress how to do a lat pulldown or
whatever so like things that they may
not be particularly exciting but there
are things that people would search for
and click on if they want to figure out
how to do something so you know how to
tie a tie how to change a tire you know
those types of videos would be the third
category and so I try to have a nice mix
of those types of videos on my channel
and I plan the topic according to what
category the video would fall into and
when you make those videos do you do
your own video editing I so I have an
editing assistant for the last couple
years
up until that point I would probably
spend like sometimes as much as like 50
60 hours per video just on editing yeah
because at the time I was like a totally
self-taught so I was like how do I get
how do I get it to highlight this part
of the study so I'd have to like and
sometimes it's not clear but you should
search for it's like I don't know click
sound effect with slight echo it's like
how do you know what to even look for to
emulate an effect you might have seen
somewhere else or whatever so it was
just like massively time consuming and
then you're trying to figure out you
know what plugins you need in this sort
of stuff so yeah the editing process was
super time-consuming for me initially so
now my videographer and editor and I
kind of split the load so I've cut that
time down from probably like 50 to 60
hours per video on like you know a good
video to maybe like five to 10 hours per
video of just editing and for me it's
usually like the the creative kind of
like finishing touches so like I like to
do the animations some of the motion
graphics some of the sound effects and
my videographer will do the basic
trimming process the audio color grade
place the b-roll that kind of thing so
we've made it much more efficient which
which is fantastic for me as a creator
because it was just not sustainable for
me initially definitely yeah when you
were in that process of becoming
self-taught were there any good
resources out there that you that you
found for anyone who might be interested
in getting into it there's no one place
that I went I would say to just watch
content closely and try to mirror it
like it's kind of the same advice I'd
give people for posing like when I
learned how to pose I didn't have any
one place like any tutorial or anything
like that that I went to I just watched
my my favorite posers like I would watch
Dexter Jackson pose and then I would go
to the mirror and try to emulate every
single move that he did a similar thing
with editing it's like there are certain
channels that I would watch like
I really like the wave oxide edits
they're videos there's a channel called
the nerd writer he does fantastic
editing veritasium is a science-based
channel that I have you know boiled some
inspiration from a bunch of others too
and I just like will see an effect and
be like oh that's really cool I think I
could do that
in this sort of Fitness context and then
it's just a lot of patience like you
have to give yourself time to experiment
look back be like oh that doesn't look
like the way I wanted it to let me see
if there's another effect I can use here
and a lot of it just comes through
through I think trial and error and
familiarizing yourself with what looks
good on other successful channels paying
close attention to that yeah one of the
things about your videos aside from just
the production quality is you do try to
make them very much evidence based a lot
of times do you have a special process
in place for like your process for
collecting and evaluating evidence or is
it just a whole lot of time on pubmed
basically um so I actually have a
research assistant at this point too who
kind of helps me collect the body of
literature the best I can so a lot of
people don't realize this with my videos
like you know maybe four or five studies
might make the final cut that I kind of
you know to maybe explain the methods on
a little bit give a bit of background
maybe list a limitation or two and then
a practical take away but when I start a
topic my assistant will send me pretty
much like usually it's around 20 to 25
studies like if there's a systematic
review he'll make sure to include you
know one of those in there and then I'll
kind of go through everything and I
would imagine it's probably fairly
similar to what you do with mastics if
you're doing it more in chronological
order whereas I'm trying to be like okay
what is the best overall picture I can
get from the body of literature on any
given topic and then I start really
trimming away and the trimming away part
is the part that I find hard because
sometimes I'll write a script for a
video or I'll have you know my notes of
the summer
of all the different studies and I'm
like this is important and I'd like to
talk about it but it's gonna take me ten
minutes and I just that would just
absolutely kill my views because people
just don't have the attention span for
it so from an outreach and a content
creation perspective you you just have
to consider the platform that you're
posting to and on YouTube people want
the information delivered in a form
that's practical and that they can
understand that's kind of snappy and so
that filtering down process is something
I've had to learn over time and so yeah
do you get back to the original question
for me now I feel like I've been reading
the literature for long enough that like
you know if I'm gonna do a video on an
exercise or a body part or a you know
training volume or something like that I
know I know where to look like I'll do a
quick search in mass I'll do a search on
James Kriegers research review read his
you know it's a video on frequency I'll
read his frequency Bible go through the
reference trail there pick out a few
studies maybe ones that I found to be
particularly high in quality or more
interesting and cover those in a little
more detail but there's just so many
good resources out there like mass for
example and these other research reviews
that I don't need to do all that legwork
myself and then when I combine that with
my my assistant who helps me out it's
just I've been able to cut that process
down to be pretty quick so you mentioned
the duration of your videos on YouTube I
don't claim to be a content strategy
expert but a lot of our market research
indicates the sweet spot for a lot of
stuff is usually about four hours a lot
of people who keep telling us our
podcasts are too short and we got to get
that four hour threshold so that's free
advice take it or leave it
okay so for me I find once it starts
getting in the ten to fifteen minute
range performance takes a pretty big hit
for me the sweet spot is around like
seven to ten minutes which admittedly it
is tough to do a top
justice in that timeframe but I know I
try to hold myself to a standard that
I'm not gonna I try to if there's
limitations to a study that are relevant
I do everything in my power to at least
mention them like I'm not I'm doing my
best not to just say this study found X
there it is take that information and
now go do this you know what I mean
so the time constraint thing is is
tricky because to do some topics justice
you you almost need you know 15 to 20
minutes and if I really do think I need
that amount of time I will take that
extra time and just take the hit on the
view count which i think is worth it
but again that kind of gets back to the
type of video that I'm trying to make
like am i trying to reach a lot of
people with some good information here
or am I trying to cater to more of that
like skeptical really truly interested
in science portion of my audience in
which case they don't mind watching a
longer video from you that really goes
into the weeds more that makes sense
yeah
so just kind of one question to tack
onto this so this this interview has
been you know pretty pretty kind so far
but now it's time to really hold your
feet to the fire
not really but why don't you start it
you held on you started calling this
interview was calling me a fake Nattie
so the patron saint of the right Church
right in an overall loving way I was
right yeah so on the topic of say like
your body part guide videos one of the
one of the few criticisms I frequently
see levelled at you just various places
on the Internet is a lot of people seem
to be of the idea that either you rely
on EMG studies too much for exercise
recommendations or like interpret EMG
research uncritically my I mean I've
seen some of those videos and my
was always that like you probably
understand the methods better than you
explained in the video probably due to
the length constraints like you just
talked about but that is something that
I see people bring up a fair amount when
your name gets mentioned so would you
like to talk about that just a little
bit so you know how you evaluate say EMG
research compared to longitudinal data
and how that you know just how different
different types of evidence affect your
thinking in general and how you use EMG
research specifically mm-hmm yeah I hear
that a nice bit too and when I hear it
it's like you'd almost think that all my
videos are just peppered with all this
EMG evidence and I'm making strong
recommendations based off those I don't
think that's the case I think it's more
of a selection bias in a sense that keep
the videos that have been the most
successful are obviously the ones that
most people are watching and they just
so happen to be these more you know
click Beatty type videos where it's like
you know the best way to train biceps or
whatever and if I'm doing an overhaul of
all the research on biceps
I mean invariably you're gonna have to
cover the the EMG evidence that's on it
and so I think that if you look at my
content as a whole there's not I don't
think there's a nearly as much EMG
evidence in there as people who levy
this criticism at me might think and I
think this tends to come from people who
aren't maybe closely following my
content but maybe just watch those body
part videos which admittedly they are my
most popular videos but they occupy a
pretty small subset of what I did like
I've done interviews with we thought you
guys lots of other experts in the field
I have lots of videos on nutrition and
videos on just like jet most of my
videos lately have been on just general
programming stuff where I'm not looking
at EMG evidence at all it's not even an
afterthought it's just not included and
when you look at you know it's
unfortunate because I did this whole
series on YouTube called the fundamental
series and
I did it with the sole intention of
framing how my entire methodology looks
from the bottom up and I said I'm not
gonna you know it it almost feels wrong
to clickbait those videos in the same
way that I would a body part video
because it's like well this is meant to
be just pure information you know and
it's just me in front of a whiteboard
and no clickbait nothing like that and
there's some of my most least popular
videos but I think they've really go
through exactly how it is I think about
training from the bottom up so it's like
you know you've got sustainability and
longevity that's the first thing
combined with safety you need to apply
an appropriate effort in the gym because
it doesn't matter how well you've got
all the other stuff set up if you're not
training hard then none of the other
stuff is gonna work and then you know
you've got progressive overload
prioritization and all the other acute
training variables like volume intensity
frequency exercise selection is like way
up at the top right so already relative
to the other stuff I think exercise
selection is not a priority in my own
hierarchy and then when it comes to
exercise selection which you know EMG
evidence would be a subset of I actually
wouldn't put a lot of stock in EMG I
what I the way I think about it is that
you want to think about the exercise in
terms of its biomechanics so
biomechanically does it make sense that
this muscle would activate the muscle
you're trying to target and does it do
it you know I'm more in a lengthened
does it apply more attention in a
lengthened position or a shortened
position or what have you in the case of
by articular muscles there's some some
concerns there with exercise selection
and I would always default to
biomechanics before the EMG evidence
when EMG evidence matches with
biomechanics I think you can borrow some
clues from it interesting we're like
more like tossing it in as like backing
up exactly yeah there what you're
already making instead right primary
thing you're leaning on so for example
with
the rear the rear delts obviously a
reverse PEC deck is going to target the
rear delts well I probably would have
mentioned in my shoulder video that you
know there's a study from Schoenfeld and
colleagues that if you externally rotate
on the reverse PEC deck so point your
thumbs up you get more average EMG
activation in the rear delts that way
then doing it with the palms down which
I found surprising because I would have
thought that you know the rear delts
biomechanically would be more unlocked
in the line with the application of
tension with a more neutral or more
internally rotated position but that's
not what they found
maybe that's because the rear delts do
contribute to external rotation slightly
so they're more activated that way but
it leads you to think okay maybe I
should experiment with different hand
positions on the on the reverse PEC deck
and see which hand position feels the
best for me now if it wasn't for that
EMG study we would never think to do
that based on biomechanics alone right
so that's where I think EMG can enter
the equation and that's really about as
far as it goes for me I did another
video critiquing EMG based on that
Vygotsky paper I think it was from 2017
were they and he tweeted about this a
couple days ago too they pretty much
throughout EMG as a viable method right
he very aware of that paper yeah okay so
I mean you probably talked about it so
he pretty much said like it's not even
measuring activation it's it's measuring
amplitude so like from a communication
perspective it's a bit of a misnomer to
say muscle activation you should be
saying most EMG amplitude and then there
are all these instances where muscle
activation disassociates from a muscle
protein synthesis and then there are
these instances where muscle protein
synthesis disassociates from
longitudinal muscle hypertrophy so is
this even a reasonable tool to be using
in research I think that was the basic
just of the paper and now just I think a
couple weeks ago I saw him tweet out
like now everyone who's doing EMG
research his citing our paper as a
limitation
but he's like that wasn't our intention
with the paper our intention with the
paper was to question your entire
methodology and say is there even any
place for this in physiotherapy
conditions and I've talked about that
paper somewhat critically on my channel
I spoke about it with yarn tromelin
who's an actual muscle protein synthesis
researcher he said he kind of disagrees
with it because he thinks that muscle
protein synthesis well let me just
follow the whole chain muscle activation
is predictive of MPs and MPs is
predictive of hypertrophy despite there
being some counter evidence that
suggests the contrary
and so I've entertained all of these
ideas on my channel multiple times but
then people who pick out individual
videos and say who he cited this EMG
study for the rear delt who's to say
that's to do anything for hypertrophy
well I don't know not me it's just that
you know given these time constraints I
can't list every possible caveat every
time I mention a study so hopefully that
clarifies that a little bit no I agree
with you there and I think one of the
things people miss when people talk
about research whether it's on YouTube
or if they write about it on social
media etc just wherever someone's
talking about it is unless you've
actually taken the time to dig into what
is out there I think a lot of people
don't realize just kind of how limited
the body of research is so you know it
would be great if say you know you're
talking about what the best exercises
for biceps growth and there's a study
directly comparing like oh our preacher
curls or incline curls better but like
no what no it's [ __ ] doing that
research because one training studies
are are very time and labor intensive
and - who the [ __ ] gonna fund that you
know would like the the NIH wants to
treat osteoporosis and sarcopenia they
don't care if you can put another
quarter inch on your arms so yeah I mean
if you're if you're trying to make
evidence-based recommendations you have
to you have to grapple with the fact
that in a lot of areas the evidence is
quite limited not because the scientific
method wouldn't be
capable of investigating certain
questions but it's just those aren't the
types of questions being investigated so
you know you don't necessarily have the
best quality evidence you would want all
the time and so you know to some degree
you kind of have to make sense of what
you have as best you can and yeah that's
that's my slight rant on the topic but I
agree very strongly with with everything
you just said cool I mean just to even
make it more clear I mean we could throw
out all of the EMG evidence I've ever
cited and just say it's all just noise
you shouldn't look into it at all which
I don't think is the case like I think
in some cases where the biomechanics
aren't perfectly clear and you're
looking at different tweaks I think that
those differences even in regional
activation or whatever can point towards
practically relevant training
modifications but let's just say we were
to throw it all out I really don't think
it would budge my overall training
philosophy at all really
whereas you know my critics who come
from this angle seem to think that if
you swipe out the EMG everything else is
just going to come tumbling down that
could not be further from the truth
but I can't say that every time I'm in
and I sometimes I do there was even a
while that I started saying EMG
amplitude and I was like this just
sounds people like can we just assume
that like for the most part a higher
amplitude is indicative of higher
activation and just from a command
communication perspective let's just
make that approximation I actually spoke
with Brett about the same issue because
this is something that obviously keeps
coming up but when I just hear this like
lowest-common-denominator
criticism against me I'm like I've said
this so many times you just haven't been
paying attention you know well I mean
and that's one of the tricky things is
like Greg and I both there are instances
where we have to do like you know
science communication as like a journal
article like a scientific publication
and there is this tendency even in
non-academic settings that you want to
get your wording perfect and then you
look back and you're like Jesus
yeah that's insane like I need
just talk the way a person would talk
like I'm getting so caught in in the the
little details I mean it what you're
explaining totally makes sense given the
context you know yeah
well Jeff we've been talking to you for
a long time we sincerely appreciate your
time but we don't want to keep you all
day it's been awesome talking to you we
really appreciate that you would join us
today but before we leave for people who
want to check out your work or for
people who want to interact with you
online where can people find you YouTube
is where I spend most of my time so if
you're just YouTube Jeff Nippert you'll
find me there also decently active on
Instagram I have a podcast as well but
not nearly as active as you guys are so
YouTube is the best place to find me
these days
awesome well thanks so much for your
time and we'll talk to you soon
thanks guys thanks for listening to the
stronger by science podcast now Greg and
I are not experts in medicine or health
or really anything else for that matter
so before you make any changes to your
diet and exercise habits make sure you
check with a doctor or another
healthcare professional if you enjoyed
this podcast and you'd like to support
it visit stronger by science com to
check out the products and services that
we offer thanks for listening and we'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you